so we previously talked about propaganda
o'clock this is the twice a day
briefings for President Trump from his
propaganda team where they would bring
him printouts of positive news and
headlines pictures of Trump really
really wacky right they would like print
tweets from the internet onto physical
paper print pictures or titles from Fox
News of Trump looking presidential or
positive titles and hand them to Trump
physically really oddball but Trump
demands it or at least someone figured
out that it keeps Trump more docile to
give him this propaganda folder we've
actually now learned about another layer
of this internal propaganda strategy
that Trump's team employs with him which
is that the staff insulates him from all
polls that have his approval in the mid
30s and instead just brings him good but
completely delusional approval polls
they'll bring him for example internal
approval polls only of Trump supporters
where he has mostly retained support or
polls that are just known to lean very
far to the right like Rasmussen which
recently showed him at 46% still no
miracle but higher than the mid 30s that
the more reputable polls have been
showing but interestingly in the last
couple days even Rasmussen now has Trump
down at 41% it's also been reported that
some White House insiders are not
thrilled with this strategy they say
listen these internal polls are
delusional they serve no real positive
purpose it's it's not it doesn't do
anything for us to show Trump these
polls but the issue is that it's
altogether too much time being spent
validating Trump's self-image by his
staff instead of doing stuff and I
wonder just Trump really not search
Google does he really think that every
poll mentioned on just about every TV
channel is fake well he did once say
that remember back in February when
Donald Trump tweeted any negative polls
or fake news just like the CNN ABC NBC
polls in the election sorry
people want border security and extreme
vetting how funny is it that Trump
denounces fake news but is kept happy
with fake or incredibly
dude news and meanwhile Trump's approval
rating in the Gallup poll is 38% it did
pop up a tiny bit over the last few days
the fivethirtyeight.com daily tracking
of all approval polls has trump at an
average approval of 38 and if it weren't
so catastrophic for our country I would
just be laughing about how insecure and
obsessed with himself Donald Trump is
but unfortunately it's having a real
impact right it's destroying our
relationships with world leaders around
the world it's already forced the United
States to take a back seat in lots of
important discussions and as I've said
now when the world meets to decide how
to deal with climate change uh you just
don't talk to Donald Trump you don't
need to talk to the to the American
president because there's no point in it
when the world meets to talk about
alternative renewable energy sources
they don't need to get the United States
involved because in the end it's Trump
and he has nothing to add on those
issues so it would be funny if it
weren't part of this significantly
destructive status quo that we have
around the world when it comes to the
President of the United States today's
program sponsor is live lingua the
immersive language learning system I've
talked about how English is not my first
language I'm a native speaker of Spanish
I learned English when I came to the
United States as a kid and I've also had
experiences trying to learn both French
and Hebrew sort of with varying degrees
of success at different points in my
life and it's a journey it's a challenge
but it really is one of the most
rewarding experiences that that I've had
particularly after learning English and
trying to learn another language and
live lingua in addition to offering
their first lesson for free has a black
friday deal going instead of buying
tchotchkes after waiting all night at
some department store what about saving
20% off of a gift card at live lingua
where you can take advantage of their
immersive learning with native speakers
of the languages they teach the 11 most
widely spoken languages in the world and
you don't have to drive around and go
meet in person with your expensive
language tutor the meetings are via
Skype they
our one-on-one and in addition to a free
lesson on Black Friday you can save 20
percent if you go to live lingua calm
slash Pakman and get a gift card and by
the way live lingua won't say anything
if you decide to use the gift card on
yourself instead of giving it to
somebody else check it out
live lingua calm slash Pakman get 20%
off all gift cards on Black Friday learn
a language